[Music]
the rental market is getting more and
more competitive really than ever yeah
in fact a new report by realtor.com
shows the average american is paying for
rent is now 30 percent of their income
as joe moeller shows us las vegas is one
of the most competitive markets he's
live at paradise and twain with more on
that joe
according to that report las vegas is
the seventh least affordable major city
in the united states when you compare
rent to income rent doesn't seem to be
going down anytime soon as well some say
it is a lot cheaper to find a room at a
home or a roommate
rents have definitely skyrocketed in a
competitive rental market more people
are switching gears it's definitely much
more affordable to rent a room but you
have to weigh
the pros and the cons shirley cessna
rents a room in a home she says she
saves several hundred dollars when
comparing renting an apartment i would
say maybe
about 500 dollars cessna says rental
prices are up making finding something
affordable very difficult recently the
prices have been more than doubling all
rent is up realtor.com reports the
median rent in las vegas is now one
thousand six hundred dollars that's 39
percent of the local average income much
higher than the national 30 percent
average cessna says it is getting more
competitive but she says there is a lot
to think about when renting a room the
cons of course being your safety
sometimes your comfort compared to the
pro of saving a few dollars while you're
being able to afford something for
yourself whether you are finding a room
a roommate or a house the rental market
is simply cutthroat it's awful
it's scarce despite an already low
supply kathy brooks says trying to find
a house to take her and her three dogs
is proving to be difficult an issue many
are running into a single-family home of
a certain size in a certain price range
you know with a certain geographic
parameter and then you add dogs and the
number goes from like there's this many
and it goes
really really fast
the report also states the average rent
is up in las vegas 25 percent compared
to this time last year reporting live at
paradise and 20 joe muller live local
now